So the question that
we have to address is
if we've got these sort of thousands
of features per image, and
maybe millions or hundreds of
millions of images or patches.
You know, what's an efficient
way to search to figure out
which image had about
the same sets of patches or
at least has a high overlap in the set
of patches that I find in a new image.
And what we do is we take a little bit
of inspiration from other systems that
have lots of little instances in them,
namely things like words and
indices, right.
So if I've got a book, it would be
really hard to find all the examples of
where it says Karl Marx in that
book by flipping through that book.
So what do we do instead,
we build an index.
Right?
There's an index in the back,
it's an efficient way to find all the
pages that contain a particular word.
Okay?
So what we want to do is we want to
find all the images from a known
database that have a particular
feature that we find.
So now what's going to happen is I'm
going to find a bunch of features
that are in a, new image.
I'm going to look up the different
images that have those features and
maybe if I find an image that has a lot
of the same features as my new image,
then I say, aha,
maybe it's the same kind of thing.
And this comes to the notion
of what we call visual words.
Okay?
So, the featured descriptors
we sometimes refer to
as visual words and
we're going to get to
code words in a minute.
But the idea is that, and
I think really this notion of words
comes from this whole
analogy with text processing.
Right?
So we've got words
are the local features and
documents are the entire image.